where this moment this magic mom hey
guys guess what i'm doing a mail vlog
and I have to start off this mail vlog
with an apology which is always the
worst way to start things off but I just
I have to one because i haven't done one
of these in so long so i apologize for
that and two because the last one went
to check my p.o box I hadn't checked it
in enough time and they sent back a
bunch of packages that people had sent
me and so I'm really really sorry I
didn't realize that there was time frame
on how long they would let the packages
stay at the post office because I am an
[ __ ] and I'm sorry but now I know
that I cannot go more than two weeks out
checking my p.o box rustles send all
your packages back so I'm very sorry
also I haven't checked it in a little
while so I have to go check it soon and
so all the mail that you're gonna see in
this vlog is probably from a long time
ago I'm so sorry I'm so sorry you don't
deserve this and I apologize it's been
travel I'll excuses won't make up for it
I'm sorry but let's get into it now on
to the fun look at this this should give
you some de notion of how I've been
living my life lately badly okay look at
all this mail Bam Bam Bam Bam yup okay
thank you guys for sending this mail
let's go through it first Molly
Montgomery from Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
Pittsburgh puts french fries on
everything therefore they are me
personified no not personify because I'm
the person version of me they're me Sid
ified whoa awkward family photos yes
yeah this is like me my dad except my
dad didn't feed me beer grace I saw this
while picking out a birthday card for my
grandpa and or reminded me of you yeah
yeah like that I take precedence over
your grandfather yay Molly Rhiannon on
Twitter Thank You Molly this is so
wonderful I had a friend in high school
named Rhiannon Somalia and thank you so
much for this this is adorable and I
will show this to my dad and be like why
was I so
hinde um next Alicia zom freely your
last name is not real and if it is real
cool hope valley Rhode Island Rhode
Island is the tiniest state I could
teach social studies great which is
spinning cuz look at this tiny little
humble everything is smaller in Rhode
Island I'm sure the guys love that flow
again hmm give it Oh what it's whoa this
is like a 3d thing it's got a little
bird in a cage is that supposed to be
symbolic of me my in a cage I'm getting
out of the cage the bird is getting out
of the cage oh it's taped on what is it
I don't understand oh I'm confused and
I'm ruining it oh it's like a little
thing that hangs is this a an ornament
maybe your I should stop asking so many
questions and Regis graves I'm sorry I
did some pretty presents like other
people but I felt like I had to write
you just to let you know how much you
helped me oh you are awesome yeah i'm
glad i could help you and whatever
you're going through everything's gonna
be okay just know that stuff takes time
to get better it does and that sucks but
that's the only thing that can happen
sometimes is that it takes time and you
can't fast forward through time you can
fast-forward through television but not
through time that wasn't very
motivational I'm sorry because who
doesn't like to smile laugh exactly you
should be smiling and laughing all the
time thank you Alicia I think I'm saying
your name right i hopes up Alicia Alicia
thank you you are sweet and I really
appreciate that card oh my gosh oh my
gosh
where are you going do you hear those
ridiculous okay look at this whoa it's a
swamp and there's a gator look at the
Gator whoa terrifying this is from
Jessica greetings from florida and she
wrote are you been hazed oh she drew
that I looks so great and there's also
oh there's a gator on this two Gators I
hate them I hate them they're not cute
to me at all thank you this is awesome I
love postcards this is from a 1 minus 1
equals 8 / 0 no no no no no no I'm gonna
open it anyway even though it's already
not appealing to me ah well this is
appealing look at that spending slightly
Spanish smileys Oh grace I love your
smile oh my gosh and just the same whose
friends I'll never know I'm never
seattle cool Thank You Seattle that was
awesome so cryptic okay what do we got
from Christina I don't know how to read
your last name sorry have fun opening
the envelope oh you taped it you love
her Oh mother I hate you I hate you and
I love you and I hate you and I'm sorry
if I ruined the card on the inside
that's your fault not mine oh yeah I did
it pretty decently surprisingly whoa
don't fall stop falling everything well
I galway of fine beans hand rose to find
coffee so look at that huh that's kill
oh it's a menu for this coffee java city
coffee service cool thanks for that
thing and then grace watching your mouth
longer minded me I needed to mail you my
bill so I decided to write you a letter
too I had this envelope left over from a
bill I had it mailed yet so here you go
yay oh and here's a menu thingy from my
school's coffee shop your school's a
coffee shop where you go someplace crazy
this is too fancy maybe school should
spend more money on the educational
budget then
the coffee shop menu budget just kidding
this is so sweet thank you I love coffee
I'll look at it oh I'll poke through it
thank you for that those are sweet this
is from a mystery person who didn't
write their name on the envelope crazies
number and your names on these envelopes
far what that is for sure give this to
me whoo okay fourfold oh well great I'm
not sure when you'll get this but I am
writing it on the Friday of vlog week
flag week was awesome I'm glad you like
it I had fun too i need to get a better
vlogging camera but that'll come
eventually i love your videos are always
funny and creative and they go well with
my morning coffee much of a very loyal
user and you don't write your name PS i
hope you win king of the web update i
just checked you're winning boop boop
yeah you be straight person you crazy
mystery person thank you for this letter
really appreciate that you took the time
to write something that's really cool of
you and I'm glad you liked me logs I
found making them okay let's see
Danielle batini ooh your name sounds
like a martini haha where you from
saylorsburg Pennsylvania whoa there's no
water no there's water in northern
Pennsylvania ray the great legs some
[ __ ] let's see you whoa best friends
dandy and grace look we're best friends
and we're so skinny my gosh we've been
working out let's see dear grace I have
been meaning to write you a letter for a
long time so I decided what better time
than your birthday you won't get the
sled on your actual day of course but I
just wanted to say happy birthday I hope
your busy day thank you Oh per month
later that's my fault not yours thank
you so much Danielle batini anyway think
you're gonna help you continue to make
videos for a long time and I wish you
all success the world I wish you all the
success in the world this is so awesome
that you made this now that all serious
stuff is done with I can draw fun
pictures yay
cool & Bailey should your Bailey's yeah
I'm down Mavado thank you for this
letter that was so nice of you ok oh
yeah oh my god there is candy from
England look at that candy this is like
the worst tasting candy in the world but
it's still Canady and i love it but it
tastes like this is all like licorice
candy right horse on the England has
like weird bad taste in candy I can't
have anything good there except for
Prince William O go happy birth is
someone who has a subtle and
sophisticated sense of humor it's a man
with a cake and he's got a match lit
what could happen oh my god you got me a
whoopee cushion look at that and it
comes with is this a real whoopee
cushion oh oh my gosh it's a real does
it open it does uh-oh this is where it
all breaks down because I don't know how
to do this get let me get small one that
was a small one thank you do not read
this out loud please oh okay
I ready to die in my head not out loud
thank you um someone sent me
cratenbarrel or that one chick who ever
it last time I p.o box all right let's
get into this summer Kathleen from Fort
Worth Texas do not Bend do not vent oh
my gosh I hope I dependent oh I hope
they didn't bend it and I hope I didn't
offend it too much oh my gosh whoa whoa
stripes oh wait what is this a oh it's a
wallet it's a while at made of duct tape
made of zebra tape look at this crazy oh
my gosh read this I will grace to show
how much I appreciate what you do I made
you a duct tape wallet with them
something bow on it I hope you like it
summer Kathleen thank you this is
awesome look at that boat that's so cool
and it opens and their slots for things
and then this opens and it's a walk for
money Thank You Kathleen this is awesome
that is so cool okay wow that was cool
rocky and Ren Carlson at jockey bat oh
my gosh look at that look at that I'm
into it I mean no I shouldn't I'm not
into it I'm gonna open this one oh wow
oh my gosh oh my gosh there's a lot
going on here uh-oh oops
oops oops this is not for me oh sorry
whoops didn't mean to send that I had a
friend off send something to another
friends through my p.o box and this is
not for me look good thing I don't edit
these because then you wouldn't get to
see that mistake now on to Alison and
jasmine oh and they sent letter oh my
gosh what's going on here a CD one of
the best Korean romantic comedies I've
ever seen is called my sassy girl oh my
gosh they made a copy of my sassy girl
which is a Korean romantic comedy didn't
know that those things existed Oh what's
there's so many envelopes ah Oh feather
earrings oh my gosh they said feather
earrings and a a note show me the note
oh my goodness oh and I'm overwhelmed
with things and stuff okay Oh Steph do
grace I first heard about you for my
friend Alison and I just wanted to tell
you that you're so funny and random and
pretty we tried bacon vodka and not
gonna lie was kind of gross Carolyn
drink it by itself you to put it like in
a bloody mary and then it's a lot better
just saying um I met you these feather
earrings they thought there'd be an
interesting contrast to your blondish
hair not real feathers I don't know if
you're into those or not but I hope you
like them these are so pretty thank you
and you know how you make the book look
it does contrast so nicely in the best
way possible Wow ok then there's two
other lenders in here only rush to brace
with a cat sticker on it oh my gosh
pictures of you guys oh that's you guys
that it's so cool oh my gosh in a cat oh
this cat looks like an [ __ ] thought
you were an [ __ ] do your grace your
videos are the highlights of our weekend
of the good work please kind of San
Francisco I will try to come to San
Francisco jasmine wow [ __ ] cats
everywhere you knew that
[ __ ] you knew they were [ __ ] and
then stickers oh you sent me these are
gonna go to good use thank you so much
whoa okay and then another letter you
guys were so much one thing oh my yeah
yeah hi how are you i want to take the
time to write you and thank you for your
videos i love them and you are so funny
i even got my friend hooked on your
videos yeah you girls rule girls and guy
rule you want rule don't rules rules
rules okay i gotta move forward I gotta
move forward I'm gonna put all this
going get back in look go back in there
earrings up Janelle Harris quiet view
lane alpine california oh you must be so
quiet or not it's like how okay I girl
sex a little chat explore super wild in
my life what's that live on quiet lane
must be obnoxious just kidding oh my
gosh what's happening aah pop up oh my
gosh Janelle you made and you made a pop
up what's up oh that's crazy let your
issues I'm announcing everything huh oh
you put some girls in here that's
adorable did you write that down here oh
you give me a gift of pearls this is no
nice view thank you that is adorable of
you okay and last but not least this is
class notes yes Oh mommy this I forgot
about this this is james hylton the
third grace face frame from Jimmy and
Emily look at that that you guys wow
that's so cool I saw this when i first
got all the stuffs I feel like I've
already opened this but sternness thank
you guys that's other you guys look like
a fun time look like a fun couple I know
if you're a couple we're brothers sister
wit and feet look but okay there's this
from oh my gosh
from Cornelia Ecklie from Norway what oh
my gosh smells like farts in here an
item far price it do that sometimes
candies candies used to me no no region
candies Oh Melek so Jupiter obnoxiously
long candy name and beaver Peter can use
the third note I think there's a note in
you open open here i will open here I'm
so aggressively excited about oh and go
give this how's it going in New York
grace good fantastic my name is Cornelia
and I'm a 15 year old girl from Norway
thought i'd send you some norwegian
candy since my initial plan of getting
temples Bailey's flied out to you kind
of went down the drain much like my fake
ID at the liquor store uh I commend you
on your attempts um thank you so much
for candy I'm gonna taste it on camera
right now so that if I have some sort of
poisoning you all know where that came
from get open don't use your teeth at
home oh my gosh chocolate chocolate
chocolate chocolate chocolate I haven't
had dinner again I'm gonna chop it up
mmm a trail of chocolate oh my mom this
is really good chocolate it tastes like
um you know chocolate on the outside of
cranberries look up that is so good oh
my god yeah now on try this crazy beeler
things they're about cars only in Norway
and crazy good probably very nice
no please don't taste like crap hmm it's
like half marshmallow half gusher oh
it's such a pleasure combination oh my
gosh guys thank you so much for the mail
you all rock and roll em mmm babe